- Tasty in the front and just like
bam, bam, bam,
punch you in your dick on the way out.
(electronic music)
- I think I can handle spicy food.
The only thing is I get the hiccups
when I eat spicy food so.
- I don't take spicy food too well.
- I'm not intimidated by spicy food.
That's a cute dog.
- When I was a child my grandma
used to spike my food with spice
to make sure I could handle it.
- Oh this is a challenge?
- Oh, (bleep).
- This smells good so.
- Oh my God, okay, okay.
- Oh.
- Oh, oh boy.
- Yeah I feel it but it's not that bad.
- It's definitely a painful spice
rather than a flavorful spice.
- Oh my God, I'm such a white person.
- Water, water.
Oh man, I need your water, Zack.
- Oh I get the hiccups every
time I eat sp- (hiccup)
Oh I get the hiccups every
time I eat spi- (hiccup)
- Oop see, I just hiccuped.
- I can't.
- Yeah, that would (bleep) you up.
- How much am I supposed
to eat before it hurts?
- It's definitely getting worse.
- I mean, it's good minus the pain.
- Done.
- Boom, we did it.
- I'm a bad person to get to these
like I put so much like shit in my body.
- I have a whole bunch on my face
so my face is burning.
- Look at my fingers.
- I think my tongue grew two sizes.
- I'm not Korean but I'm
Asian so it's like, you know.
- I think my grandma won against everyone.
She's like, "Oh you're sad that
I spiked your food with spice?
Well listen, I lived through
two revolutions, bitch."